for most of its life the CIA was banned
from propagandizing Americans
but we learned that they were doing it
anyway so in 1973 during the church
committee hearings we learned
that the CIA had a program called
operation Mockingbird
where they had at least 400 members
leading members of the United States
press Corps
and the New York Times The Washington
Post ABC CBS NBC Etc
who were secretly working for the agency
and um and steering news coverage uh to
support CIA priorities
and they agreed at that time to disband
operation Mockingbird in 73.
but there's there's indications they
didn't do that and they still the CIA
today is the biggest funder of
Journalism around the world
the biggest funder is through usaid
I'm the USA the United States funds
journalism in almost every country in
the world you know it owns newspapers it
has journalists on thousands and
thousands of journalists on its payroll
they're not supposed to be doing that in
the United States but um you know in
President Obama changed the law to make
it legal now for the CIA to propagandize
Americans and I think you know we can't
look at the Ukraine war and how that was
you know has been how the narrative has
been formed in the in the minds of
Americans
and say that the CIA had nothing to do
with that what is the mechanism I wish
to say influences The Narrative do you
think it's interesting through the Press
indirectly through the press or directly
by funding the Press directly through
I mean there's certain press organs that
have been linked you know to the agency
that the people who run those organs uh
things like The Daily Beast now rolling
you know editor of note Rolling Stone
Noah schlachmann
as deep relationships with the
intelligence Community a salon
daily coasts
um but I wonder why they would do it so
from my perspective it just seems like
the job of a journalist is to have an
Integrity where European cannot be
influenced or bought I agree with you
but I actually think that the entire
field of Journalism has uh
has uh you know really ashamed itself in
recent years because it's become you
know the the principal newspapers in
this country and the television station
the Legacy Media
have abandoned their
um
they're traditional their tradition of
of you know which was when I was a kid
listen my house was filled with the
greatest journalists alive at that time
people like Ben Bradley like Anthony
Lewis Mary mcgrory
eat Hamill Jerry Jack Newfield uh Jimmy
Breslin
uh uh and many many others and after my
father after my father died they started
the RFK journalism Awards
to recognize integrity and courage you
know journalistic interior courage and
for that generation of Journalism
they they thought they believed that
that the function of a journalist was to
maintain this posture of fear skepticism
toward any aggregation of power and
including government Authority
that you always the people in Authority
lie and that way they always have to be
questioned and uh and that their job was
to speak truth power and to be Guardians
of the First Amendment right to to uh
free expression
but if you look what happened during the
pandemic
it was the inverse of that kind of
Journalism where
the uh the major press organs in this
country
were instead of speaking truth to power
they were doing the opposite they were
Broadcasting
propaganda they became propaganda organs
for the government agencies and they
were actually censoring
um the speech of anybody who descends of
the powerless
oh and it in fact it was it was an
organized conspiracy you know and it was
the name of it was The Trusted news
initiative and you know some of the
major press organs in our country signed
on to it and they agreed
not to print stories or facts that um
that departed from government Orthodoxy
so the Washington Post was the signature
of the UPI
the AP and then the um the four Media or
the four social media on groups
Microsoft Twitter
uh Facebook and Google all signed on to
the trusted news initiative it was
started by the BBC organized by them
and the purpose of it
was to make sure nobody could print
anything about government that departed
from government Orthodox is the way it
worked is the UPI and the AP and the
which are the news services that provide
most of the new you know news around the
country and the Washington Post would
decide what news was permissible to
print
and a lot of it was about covet but also
Hunter finds laptops where you it was
the impermissible to suggest that those
were real or that you know they had
stuff on there that was compromising
and um
and we you know and by the way
I this is what I'm telling you is all
well documented and I'm litigating on it
right now so I'm part of a lawsuit
against the dni
and so I know a lot about what happened
and I have all this documented and
people can go to our website there's a
letter
on my substack now to um to Michael's
share of the Washington Post that
outlines all this and gives all my
sources
um because Michael share accused me of
being a conspiracy theorist when he was
actually part of a conspiracy a true
conspiracy
to suppress anybody
who is departing from governmental
orthodoxies by either censoring them
completely or labeling them conspiracy
theorists
I I mean you can understand the
intention
and the action the difference between as
we talked about you can understand the
intention of such a thing being good in
a time of a catastrophe a time of a
pandemic there's a lot of risk to saying
untrue things but that's a slippery
slope that leads into yeah a place where
the journalistic Integrity that we
talked about is completely sacrificed
and then you can deviate from truth if
you read their internal memorandum
including the statements of the the
leader of the trusted news initiative I
think her name's Jessica uh Jennifer to
see so
um and I you know you can go on our
website and see her say amen and she
said she says
the purpose of this is that we're an
ally she says when people look at us
they think we're competitors but we're
not the real competitors are coming from
all these alternative news sources now
all up with an Edward uh and they're
hurting public trust in us and they're
hurting our economic model and we have
to they have to be choked off and
crushed and uh and the way that we're
going to do that is to
make an agreement with the social media
sites that if we say if we label their
information misinformation the social
media sites will um will de-platform it
or they will throttle it or they will uh
Shadow ban it
which destroys the economic model of
those alternative competitive sources of
information so that that's true but and
but the point you make is an important
point
um that the journalists themselves
who probably didn't know about the TNI
agreement certainly I'm sure they didn't
um they believe that they're doing the
right thing by suppressing information
that May challenge you know government
proclamations on covet
but I mean there's a danger to that and
the danger is that
you know once you appoint yourself an
Arbiter of what's true and what's not
true
uh and there's really no end to the
power that you have now assumed for
yourself because
now your your job is no longer to inform
the public your job now is to manipulate
the public
and if you end up manipulating the
public uh in collusion with powerful
entities then you become the instrument
of authoritarian rule rather than the
you know the the opponent of it and it
becomes the inverse of Journalism in a
democracy